and then so when you start to think
through uh the ultimate vision of
lightning um
what does that look like like where are
we headed or what's the thing that has
everyone excited as to if lightning is
successful here's what the lightning
network can actually achieve
yeah i mean i think it's the way i
really see it is it's uh it's really
building that new internet right and i
think that's maybe a little it's
probably used pretty often in the crypto
space and it's maybe a little overused
but like but seriously like when you
think about the being able to use
money just like the way that we use tcp
today and being able to send satoshi's
like in in along with this image or a
message or whatever it is um it really
is a really crazy and novel idea to be
able to send money the way that we send
the internet packets right and when
people are applying that to things like
the chat applications being able to
listen to podcasts and stream money to
the creator
it really it creates a relationship
between the content creator and the
consumer it's like this one-to-one and
you can do it completely peer-to-peer
and be able to uh really do all these
new things that are on top of the
lighting network that haven't really
been able to be done before or at least
if something was similar you had to
trust some intermediary you had to like
use venmo or something to like be a
middleman in between these these things
um and so it's really
unlocking a whole new way of
uh sending sending the value between
people and is doing it in a way that is
also could be super finite right you can
send fractions of a cent to someone um
you know over and over and over again
for like imagine sending someone a venmo
for one cent
for an hour like who like that's crazy
but being able to do that while you're
listening to a podcast or messaging
whatever it is um it's really unlocking
a whole new way that we use the internet
when you think about lightning being
built and continuing to kind of um gain
adoption infrastructure is obviously
really important you run a business
called voltage that is specifically
focused on uh bitcoin infrastructure
made easy what is voltage and how does
the product work
yeah for sure so yeah we're a bitcoin
infrastructure provider so we've created
a platform that makes it super easy to
spin up bitcoin nodes and lightning
nodes along with some other open source
technology that makes those even easier
to use so through our platform you can
come sign up and create a note in about
two minutes and be up and running on the
lightning network um really i created
this the platform out of the frustration
of trying to set up a node myself and
really get on to the network and
spending hundreds of dollars only to
have everything fail and the maintenance
so we really created a platform that is
super easy to use and uh gets you up and
running uh like in two minutes and we
handle all the
non sexy stuff on the back end of
networking backups all of this stuff so
uh you can come create a node and hook
up your wallet or just hit the apis
directly and just get started using the
lightning network in
virtually no time at all
so if i'm a user i come to voltage and i
say i'd like to split up a lightning
node what's happening on the back end
what is what is the work that you're
having to do uh for me uh to get me set
up and off to the races
yeah so we have a i mean we have a
pretty complex like back-end system that
uh handles a lot of things but really
when you're creating a node a lightning
node uh it has to connect into a bitcoin
full node because it has to validate
those transactions onto the main chain
and then uh we're you also have to do
the bootstrapping of like the network
which is like graph syncing to figure
out okay where are the other nodes at on
the network um and then you also have to
set up all of your settings to enable
which apis you want what kind of backups
you want all of these uh really
intricate details um so we really handle
all of those that provisioning of your
node the bitcoin node uh connecting into
the other network do finding than
finding the other nodes on the network
and so the whole bootstrapping process
is what we create or what we manage for
you and then uh taking that step further
into once you start using the product
doing things like version upgrades and
uh trying to do uh
failover some new nodes all of those
things you know we have solutions for
and so obviously i think this is super
fascinating uh and a really valuable
business idea so much so that i invested
in the business but what metrics can you
share with us some kind of progress to
date or any signs that you have of okay
voltage works and people want to use
this
yeah for sure i mean we have a pretty
extensive list of uh customers that are
fairly popular in the lightning network
space so you can think about like um
adam curry and his podcast index and uh
dave jones they are using us to manage
their lighting note and they're
when when the whole podcasting 2.0 uh
movement that's going on right now they
receive like a portion of virtually all
podcasts that are getting played and so
that's a huge amount of volume going to
their node and uh that was something
that the
they really didn't know much about and
the they couldn't manage a whole lot
they didn't have the time to manage all
this stuff so that's where voltage
really came in to
take over that for them and they can
start working with all these companies
to enable this podcasting 2.0 um and
then we think about people like sphinx
chat and the zion that just got released
today these are uh
pretty new way of doing um the lightning
network in that they provision knows on
behalf of users and then you know when
you sign up you are you know assigned a
node um and those are in the thousands
of nodes you know for for their
customers um so
we really uh we've really seen some good
success both in like the size of nodes
and like the size of volume that is
coming through the platform and then
also just strictly in the number of
nodes it's been pretty vast as well so
uh there's a lot of different use cases
a lot of different markets that are
coming into play here um but all of them
are really uh i think seeing seeing
value out of the platform and are really
onboarding in a big way
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com
so that you can get an account and we
can get after it